ja dann auch noch mal ein herzlich
willkommen von mir mein vortrag wird
jetzt eher noch mal so eine einführung
in das thema wissen gerade
problembeschreibung weil ich am ende
auch keine lösungsvorschläge wirklich
parat habe aber ich habe ja auch zum
einstieg noch mal unser logo einmal
mitgebracht also dieses jungen yan
symbol hatten wir da und die frage war
ja gibt es widersprüche oder synergien
oder zumindest kontaktpunkte zwischen
forschung und lehre das ganze möchte ich
jetzt ein bisschen mehr aus
naturwissenschaftlicher sicht
beschreiben wobei ein bisschen waghalsig
ist gleich die ganze natur wissenschaft
beschreiben zu freuen dass er so ein
persönlicher erfahrungsbericht von mir
deswegen kann ich das ganze auch mal den
versuch einer standort versuch einer
standortbestimmung genannt weiblichen
erfahrungsbericht gut
ich spring mal von unseren jungen jahren
was so diese verbundenheit gezeigt hat
weil ich habe schon oft auseinander
gezupft
das ist wohl eher die vorstellung die
sich dann meistens grad die
wissenschaftler sich dieses doppelspiel
auf forschung und lehre vor spielen
haben wir eben ja auch schon gehört wir
haben die forschung er auf der einen
seite werden die lehrer auf der anderen
seite die wir haben beide eigentlich gar
nicht viel miteinander zu tun und die
forschung ist sich der viel wichtigere
teil von dem ganzen der entscheidende
punkt ist wahrscheinlich auch dafür ein
die karriere anreize liegen hat auf
seiten der forschung
deswegen geht die lehre immer so ein
bisschen dabei unter jetzt haben wir uns
als dozierenden netzwerk bzw
bei dem symposium hier vorgenommen das
ganze doch mehr noch mal aus sicht von
dozierenden und auch von der lehre oder
den studierenden aus zu sehen
deswegen versuche ich es trotzdem mal
auf das ganze eher von der lehre aus da
hinzuschauen und kann man nicht von der
lehre doch irgendwie zur forschung
kommen oder in die nähe der forschung
kommen
ach ja leicht hätte eben schon gesagt
nicht einig ist dass unsere aufgabe auch
dabei und ich habe zwei stellen aus dem
hochschulrahmengesetz mann mitgebracht
da heißt nämlich die universitäten
dienen vornehmlich der forschung und
lehre und verbinden diese vor einer
vorwiegend wissenschaft bezogenen
ausbildung und wenn man dann weiter
runter lief ist unter studienziele dann
die aufgabe lehre und studium sollen die
studierenden einmal auf eine berufliche
tätigkeit vor ausbilden
nach vorbereiten und das ganze so machen
dass sie zu einer wissenschaftlichen
oder künstlerischen arbeit aber auch
befähigt werden
das heißt das wissenschaftliche arbeiten
ist eigentlich per hochschulrahmengesetz
doch bei uns verankert
dann machen wir mal den versuch und
freuen uns die forschung irgendwie in
das studium mit integrieren
ich hab da mal ein bisschen nach
begriffen gesucht ich sag ja schon ich
bin kein experte da auf dem feld und die
tiere jetzt mal 1 5 kuba er hat sich
begriffe um das feld forschendes lernen
quasi etwas sortiert hat auch wenn die
begriffe sage ich gleich nicht von allen
quasi genau in dem sinne immer benutzt
werden
wir sehen einmal unten die grundlagen
erstmal werden überhaupt weil der
wissenschaftliche stand gelehrt dass man
in vorlesungen was noch in lehrbüchern
halt lesen kann ist aber nicht das
forschen was direkt da gelehrt wird
das kommt natürlich drüber
zusammengefasst unter forschungsnahe es
lernen ein punkt wäre
forschungsbasiertes lehren und lernen
hier genannt also dann abgekürzt man
reflektiert war den forschungsprozess
man stellt sich forschungsfragen wie
könnte man rangehen wir sind andere da
rangegangen und versucht kurse in den
forschungsprozess nachzuvollziehen
dann ein besuch forschungsorientiertes
lehren und lernen da geht etwas mehr
richtung forschung also das forschen mit
weise ein bisschen geübt
gerade in den naturwissenschaften wäre
sie von den methoden lernen auch im
labor was mache ich da wie wertig was
aus die mache ich ein experiment wie
finde ich eine fragestellung also das
forschen mit quasi im kleinen so ein
bisschen getestet und dann habe ich den
begriff forschendes lernen
das werden der punkt wo ist die
studierende wirklich selber forschen und
an der stelle möchte ich ein zitat
einmal zeigen und zwar ihr forschende
lernen zeichnet sich jetzt von den
anderen lernen von dadurch aus
dass sie lernen den prozess jetzt in
allen phasen in den wesentlichen phasen
wird dich selber mitmachen und das
entweder in einer selbständigen arbeit
oder als in aktiver mitarbeit in einem
größeren projekt
diese beiden punkte die will ich jetzt
ganz gerne noch weil wir die abbildung
somit integrieren und zwar in dieses
eigene forschen kann also einmal
stattfinden die studierenden machen ein
eigenes kleines projekt sie forschen da
vor sich hin
das ganze ist aber nicht in die
wirkliche richtige forschung nenne ich
mal der der betreuer integriert oder
andersrum
sie leben nicht wirklich an der
forschung teil das werden hier oben v.li
als teil der scientific community und
dafür jetzt die stelle wo wirklich
betreuer und studieren da sich zwar auf
augenhöhe dann letztendlich auch mal
begegnen können oder letztendlich auch
wirklich eine synergistische effekte
auftreten könnten also unten haben wir
den fall der dozent ist wirklich lehrern
bzw betreuer von dem ganzen und ich
glaube erst auf der stufe ganz oben
da gibt es wirklich dann synergistische
effekte zwischen betreuer und
studierende mit habe ich mal was daneben
gemalt das wird von mir auch wenn das
ganze jetzt nicht so hierarchisch
eigentlich gedacht es ist eine zeichnet
ist habe ich mich mal gefragt wann und
wo findet das einzig statt
und ich hab das mal so auf meine
erfahrung eingeteilt also die unteren
teile man lernt überhaupt erstmal
wissenschaftliche fachinhalte
beziehungsweise diese ersten formen von
forschungsbasierten und orientierten
lernen die finden durchaus den
universitäts veranstaltung die
vorlesungen seminare praktischen übungen
statt
das eigentliche forschen der
studierenden kommt aber eigentlich ganz
am ende oder eigentlich war erst nach
dem studium also ihre teilhabe an der
scientific community scheint für mich
vor allem an erst während der
promotionsarbeit stadt zu finden und ist
eigentlich gar nicht noch in das studium
integriert aber der übergang ist ehrlich
vielleicht fließend aber das meiste
richtige forschen macht man eigentlich
während der doktorarbeit
von hier aus lässt die frage kann man
hier ist wirklich richtige forschen auch
irgendwie gar nicht von den
universitätsalltag mit integrieren
man fragt warum wäre das wichtig wissen
was unterscheidet das richtige forschen
quali von abgebauten forschen und auf
meine eigenen erfahrungen es ist quasi
das man erst einmal so wirklich richtig
mal selber forscht merkt auch was aber
vollständig falsch laufen kann bzw wenn
mal was nicht funktioniert wenn man
wieder neu nachdenken mussten neue
motive entwickeln muss seine methoden
überprüfen muss und das ist alles was
dadurch indem unterrichtsforschung
sozusagen nicht wirklich stattfindet
also die betreuer kommen damit
vorgefertigten quasi auch experimenten
oder versuchen in den
naturwissenschaften
die wissen meistens schon vorher was der
student am ende raus bekommen wir den
versuch gemacht und die sich fehlerhafte
erleichtert auch gesagt man tippelt war
sie im dunkel in der richtigen forschung
das eigentlich was das richtige forschen
glaube ich dann unterscheidet von den
studentischen forschung gut aber die
frage kann man jetzt so richtiges
forschen was wir als wissenschaftler
machen wirklich in den unterricht quasi
während des studiums schon integrieren
ich möchte dass quasi an einem beispiel
mal ein bisschen erläutern
und zwar ein forschungsprojekt was sich
vielleicht irgendwo auch den letzten
tagen gelesen haben weil jetzt im
september ist der forschungsschiff
polarstern zu einer expedition
aufgebrochen
der verzicht ein außergewöhnliches
projekt und nicht der normale
forschungsalltag aber ich glaube man
kann ganz gut daran erinnern was
naturwissenschaftliche forschung
teilweise ausmacht und das ganze ist vom
alfred-wegener-institut awi geleitet von
der homepage und schon der titel derzeit
quasi als allererste problem meiner
meinung und zwar forschung ist extrem
langwierig aber die japaner jetzt ein
jahr lang durch die antarktis sammeln
daten und nur das datensammeln nimmt
schon ein jahr war die zeit in anspruch
die vorbereitungszeit von dem ganz wild
auf zehn jahre zu viert auf ihrer
homepage und dann kommt natürlich auch
die ganze auswertung dazu die ganze
veröffentlichungs prozesse am ende ist
es wahrscheinlich ein 20 jahres projekt
was die da machen und daher die frage
wie soll man das in ein
in der uni integrieren gut das kommt
auch von der homepage da ist noch ein
bisschen gezeigt was dann passieren soll
also man wichtig diese polarstern das
schiff die wollen sich so auf einer
eisscholle festfrieren lassen und sich
dann quasi mit dem eis treiben lassen
unter messdaten aufnehmen
es ist ja schon gezeigt daher ganz viele
sensoren da im 1 das ist noch ob
schrauber und flugzeuge die mit sensoren
durch die gegend fliegen
ich glaube hier von satelliten aus wird
das eis abgetastet und das kleine der
zweite punkt der in den
naturwissenschaften auftaucht
naturwissenschaftliche forschung ist
unfassbar teuer weil wir am ende sehr
der technik abhängig ist also ohne die
ganze technik und die brauchen das
schiff für dieses projekt ist diese
forschung gar nicht möglich
und der nächste punktegleich mit
reinspielt diese ganzen geräte die kann
man nicht mal gerade zu bedienen wie ein
toaster zu hause das ist schon wirklich
kompliziert die umfang bedienen können
man muss auch wissen wo man die einsetzt
und man muss natürlich die ganzen daten
die diese geräte ausspucken am ende dann
auch wir auswerten können und das
benötigt enorme vorwissen und
methodenkompetenz das ganze machen zu
können
und auch das kann man manchmal auch
nicht mit einem student einfach im
seminar machen
da reicht die zeit nicht bzw studenten
können anfang diesen ganzen datenmengen
auch überhaupt nichts anfangen
gut ich habe das ganze müsse in
schriftform quasi rübergebracht
in der mitte ist nicht so ganz stark
herunter gebrochen der forschungsprozess
auch wenn das was ich in wahrheit nicht
so stattfindet aber am anfang so
fragestellung entwerfen methoden
überlegen wie man das ganze machen
möchte dann kommt der teil der für die
naturwissenschaften sichert euch dann
charakteristisch ist
entweder werden beobachtungen gemacht
oder einfach daten gesammelt
oder andersrum werden experimente
durchgeführt
das ganze wird protokolliert werden und
dann teilweise wirklich sehr sehr
aufwändig sind analysiert werden und auf
einen rum sind jetzt ein bisschen die
punkte wieder mit reinspielen also
gerade dieses experimentieren und
beobachten ist einmal
kostspielig haben das schon gesehen wird
so quasi enorm zeit und arbeitsintensiv
sind weiter auf der anderen seite aber
mit denen die kenntnisse und methoden
mit aufgeführt die man quasi braucht uns
ganze auch bewältigen zu können
ja es hat eben auch schon die
spezialisierung mit angesprochen also
das was da gemacht wird sich sehr sehr
sehr speziell und wenn man daran
teilnehmen will muss man das ganze auch
erst mal wissen er was das thema was
sind die details und man muss auch diese
ganzen methoden erstmal beherrscht und
dann will ich mitmachen zu können
gut dann habe ich das mal ein bisschen
gegenübergestellt also diese probleme
die ich jetzt hauptsächlich sehr und
dann das wie ist eigentlich in einem
studio im studium dann sein müsste also
naturwissenschaftliche forschung ist
einmal langwierig und arbeitsaufwendig
es ist teuer und man braucht ein enormes
vorwissen bzw methodenkenntnisse und auf
der anderen seite das normale studium in
seminaren und übungen muss halt
irgendwie in semestern organisiert sein
und hat oft nur wenige
semesterwochenstunden und das ganze oder
sich zu führen dafür ja auch viele
studenten haben muss das ganze in die
massentauglich sein also die kosten
dürfen auch nicht so hoch werden
man muss für einen arbeitsplatz
überhaupt erstmal haben das dort
arbeiten können und die studenten müssen
auch ein gewisses vorwissen und methoden
kenntnis haben um überhaupt an dem
prozess teilnehmen zu können und diese
grundlagen werden eigentlich erst
während des studiums überhaupt erst mal
gelegt
deswegen kommt dass meine erste
schlussfolgerung also das forschen
wirklich in das studium zu integrieren
funktioniert quasi aus organisatorischen
gründen auf kostengründen und aus auch
von methoden kennen ist gründen schon
gar nicht erst mal vorausgesetzt
studierende und betreuen möchten das
wort einbringen
aber diese ganzen begründung glaube ich
führe dazu dass gerade in den
naturwissenschaften das so gar nicht
funktionieren würde
dann etwas zum abschluss schon die frage
was machen denn die naturwissenschaftler
jetzt eigentlich im studium
da ich meinen biologiestudium auch bei
der arbeit viele mikros kopiert haben
wir so ein bild das erstes eingefallen
das habe ich erst mal für sich auch
mitgebracht und das ist der vergleich
links wichtig ein forschungs mikroskop
und rechts die die situation wie man
mikroskopieren lernt also alle biologen
bzw alle mediziner werden so was kennen
wie das aussieht aber auf der linken
seite ist eigentlich mikroskop ist das
hier also das ist schon mal irgendwie
anders und größer aus als die auf der
anderen seite sie haben einen computer
zur bedienung die großgruppe die werden
auch nicht mit einfachen licht bedient
oder sind dann laser werden da
eingesetzt
das ganze wird noch gekühlt und
temperiert man hat das spezial tische
dass auch keine vibrationen bei der
arbeit stören
die haben ja sogar noch einen kasten
drum herum da kann man quasi eine
atmosphäre simulieren und lebende zellen
sogar untersuchen
also sind enorm aufwendiges ding was da
steht und in der regel habt auch ein
institut erwarte ich ein einziges davon
oder vielleicht das war eine uni sogar
nur ein einziges von diesen geräten
handelt sich diese geräte sind pausenlos
ausgelastet auch von wissenschaftlern
doktoranden wie lernen jetzt die
studenten das mikroskopieren nämlich in
diesem setting also viele reihen viele
kleine mikroskope und da macht man das
ganze erstmal erst mal im kleinen bis
man quasi irgendwann mal mit den großen
geräten spielen darf und also sozusagen
auch hier dann die hauptaussage also der
eigentliche forschungsprozess wird fürs
studium also für naturwissenschaftliches
erlebt habe quasi zerstückelt in immer
kleinere einheiten
das ganze soll ich die kostengünstiger
werden es muss zeitlich und
organisatorisch irgendwie bewältigbar
sein
das ganze muss auf dem wissensstand der
studierenden dann entsprechen und man
geht also zu immer kleineren einheiten
wieder zurück für die studierenden
bedeutet das dann aber sie lernen die
forschung nicht am stück also den ganzen
forschungsprozess mit höhen und tiefen
sondern sie bekommen immer noch so
kleine häppchen davon geliefert
und ich habe eben vielleicht werden
diese häppchen denn meistens auch vor
geplant also derzeit eigentlich schon
was wäre das häppchen dann passiert was
jetzt auch nicht so wirklich forschungs
typisch dann ist und auf der anderen
seite noch der lehrende der entfernt
sich quasi um so kleiner diese häppchen
werden auch immer weiter von seiner
eigentlichen forschungsarbeit also
thematisch geht man ein stück zurück bzw
auch von der technik her wird das immer
minimalisiert bis man irgendwann ein
punkt ist ja eigentlich nicht mehr der
eigenen forschung entspricht gut dann
komme ich auch schon zum schluss ich
habe eben schon gesagt ich habe auch
keine lösungsvorschläge direkt
anzubieten
formell ist erstmals als abschluss die
sie hier
aber wirklich naja synergie auf
forschung und lehre ist in den
naturwissenschaften dich nicht möglich
so wie ich das denke aber die beiden
lassen sich nicht direkt miteinander zu
verbinden
der prozess gemacht wird es halt dass
der forschung in kleinen einheiten
irgendwie präsentiert wird und die frage
wäre jetzt die aufgabe wäre jetzt wie
kann man diesen kleinen häppchen noch
möglichst gut oder möglichst qualitativ
hochwertig präsentieren also an den
häppchen gibt glaube ich kein weg vorbei
aber die frage wer dann wie kann man das
noch möglichst gut dann vielleicht
durchführen und die zweite frage wäre
natürlich dann an uns lehrende wie viel
mehr teil und zeit möchte man an diesem
jahr aspekt an widmen
damit man hat diese häppchen dann
wirklich gut quasi formulieren und
präsentieren kann
das wäre es doch so meine schlusswort
dazu dass lösungsvorschläge habe ich
erstmal nicht anzubieten aber wenn ich
unser programm geschaut habe werden wir
in den lauf von diesen beiden tagen noch
einige präsentationen hören wo glaube
ich genau das aufgegriffen wird nämlich
wo kann man nämlich diese forschung dann
irgendwo ins studium integrieren
vielen dank
[Applaus]